hola bienvenidos a la presentación sobre
sumar y restar números negativos primero
que todo lo que lo que vamos a pensar
aquí es que es un número negativo voy a
dibujar una recta numérica hao bueno el
mejor intento de una recta numérica no
está muy recta que digamos y en fin
tenemos aquí el cero y tenemos números
positivos ajá a los cuales bueno ya
estamos bastante acostumbrados cierto
entonces qué tal si yo te digo que es
dos más dos aquí tenemos el 2 y le
sumamos dos llegamos a 4 ajá entonces
dos más dos es igual a cuatro y si te
pregunto que es 2 menos uno o mejor
bueno mejor mejor ok que es 3 - 2
entonces inicias en el 3 y restas dos
llegados al 1 entonces dos más dos es
igual a 4 y 3 menos 2 es igual a 1 ahora
qué tal si yo te digo cuánto es uno
menos 3 ahí está medio truculento el
asunto tal vez pienses que es medio raro
pero es lo mismo
inicias en el 1 y avanzas 3 hacia la
izquierda del 0 entonces aquí siguen los
números negativos y tenemos al menos 1
el menos dos el menos 3 y así sigue
verdad ahora
al inicio en el 1 tengo 13 así que
avanzó 1 2 3 y ahí están llegó al menos
2 por lo tanto uno menos 3 es igual a
menos 2 y esto es algo que tú haces día
a día por ejemplo si yo te digo hoy está
haciendo mucho frío estamos a un grado
iii pero mañana hará más frío porque
estaremos a 3 grados menos que hoy
entonces tú al menos intuitivamente
dices o estaremos a menos dos grados ajá
solo recuerda que cuando cuando tenemos
un número negativo por ejemplo en este
caso en grados y tenemos menos 50 grados
eso es menos o es más frío que estar a
menos 20 grados
en este en este ejemplo tú puedes ver
que el menos 50 es un número más pequeño
que menos 20 porque está más alejado del
cero a la izquierda y bueno ya con eso
ya tenemos información sobre los números
negativos ahora hagamos unos ejercicios
voy a dibujar aquí
y una recta una recta numérica y vamos a
pensar que sería 5 menos 12
entonces dibujo la la recta numérica voy
a usar la herramienta de línea para que
ahora sí quedé recta a la recta ahí está
entonces voy a poner aquí a sus
respectivas flechas que eso no está
quedando muy bien pero ok entonces aquí
tengo menos 10 9 menos ocho menos siete
menos seis menos cinco menos cuatro creo
que no voy a tener tanto espacio menos
10 1 2 3 4 y 5 justo aquí en la en la
flecha entonces ahí tenemos los números
iniciamos con 5 y avanzamos 12 a la
izquierda porque estamos restando 12
entonces tenemos
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 y 12 entonces
menos 75 menos 12 es igual a menos 7 y
eso es bastante interesante porque
porque da la casualidad que 12 menos 5
es igual a 77 positivo ahora piensa en
esto porque 5 menos 12 es igual a menos
7 y 12 menos 5 es igual a 7 nota que
estamos diciendo que la diferencia entre
5 y 12 7 o sea que los números están a
esa distancia uno del otro siete
unidades entonces simplemente que
empezamos con el 5 que es el número
menor ahora espero no verte confundido
con eso y bueno quedamos que 5 menos 12
es igual a menos 7 que te parece si
ahora hacemos otro ejemplo que te parece
el menos 3 + 5 eso a que es igual ok
entonces vamos a iniciar ahora con menos
y avanzamos 5 a la derecha entonces aquí
sería 1 2 3 4 y 5 llegamos al 2 por lo
tanto menos 3 5 es igual a 2
lo voy a escribir acá mejor menos tres
más 5 es igual a 2 y esto es interesante
porque porque 5 menos 3 también es igual
a 2 pero ve a 5 menos 3 es lo mismo que
escribir 5 más menos 3 o menos tres más
así que una manera general de trabajar
con números negativos es pensarlo como
como una resta normal pero pero ahora
podemos avanzar más allá del cero en
dirección hacia la izquierda ahora otro
ejemplo digamos que que te parece
22 - menos 3 ok esto
esto cómo funciona esto es lo mismo que
cuando tienes dos signos negativos ellos
se cancelan entonces esto es lo mismo
que dos más más tres que es igual a
cinco y otra manera de decir esto por
ejemplo si tenemos menos 7 menos
- 2 ok aquí esto es igual a menos 7 más
2 iniciamos con el 7 y nos movemos 2
unidades hacia la derecha entonces
iniciando en el menos siete si nos
movemos una unidad a la derecha llegamos
al menos 6 y después otra unidad y
llegamos al menos 5 ahí ya tenemos las 2
unidades esto es lo mismo que dos menos
72 menos siete lo mismo que menos 72
entonces esto es igual a menos 5 ahora
hagamos un montón de ejemplos creo que
entre más ejemplos resolvamos más
expertos te volverás en esto y bueno
entonces menos 7 menos 3 aquí avanzamos
3 unidades hacia la izquierda del -7 y
eso nos lleva al menos 10 ok
ahora aquí aquí tienes que ver que 7
positivo +3 esto es igual a 10
si ves aquí la relación esto tiene
sentido cierto
hagamos unos cuantos ejemplos más porque
la práctica hace al maestro y tú tú tú
serás muy bueno haciendo esto después de
que practiques unas cuantas veces
3 - menos 3 esto aquí los signos
negativos se cancelan y nos queda igual
a 6 ahora tres menos tres es este está
fácil verdad este esto esto es igual a
cero en menos tres menos tres es igual a
menos seis estamos avanzando del -3
otras tres unidades a la izquierda del
cero ahora menos tres menos menos tres
éste está interesante porque aquí
simplemente se cancelan los signos
negativos y nos quedan menos tres más
tres ya lo hicimos esto es igual a cero
si no quedó muy claro te mostraré por
qué tiene esto sentido cualquier cosa
menos ella misma es igual a cero
entonces en este caso menos 3
2 - 3 es igual a 0
porque ya puedes ver que por eso tiene
sentido que los signos negativos se
cancelan ahora am hagamos más ejemplos
más más ejemplos muchos 12-13 este esta
sencillo cierto en 12 menos 12 es igual
a cero entonces 12 menos 13 es igual a
menos 1 otro ejemplo
8 - 5 8 5 a bueno este de hecho es este
es un problema normal pero 58 aquí
estamos
llegamos al 0 y avanzamos otras 3
unidades a la izquierda es igual a menos
3 de hecho puedo dibujar una recta
numérica así que ahí tenemos al cero y
aquí tenemos al 5 y lo que voy a hacer
es avanzar a la izquierda 8 unidades y
de esta manera llegamos al menos 3
puedes hacer esto de hecho puedes te
recomiendo que lo hagas dibuja una recta
numérica para cada uno de estos
ejercicios que hicimos sería un buen
ejercicio que lo hicieras y te lo
recomiendo ampliamente ahora bien si te
confundió un poco hay más vídeos en
estos temas pero mientras tanto
diviértete sumando y restando números
negativos nos vemos